je tiens quand même à dire que j'ai
passé une journée très particulière hier
puisque j'ai fait un kiffe je chantais
avec Nadia à 18h10 à minuit j'étais
encore avec Gérald Darmanin et c'est ça
la vraie vie c'est ça la vraie vie c'est
de passer de Phil Barney à Gérard
Darmanin de Colonel Reyel aurélie n'a
que 16 ans mais ça l'attend en enfant
regardez
Cyril Hanouna et le seul animateur de
France capable dans la même journée
d'ambiancer son public en chantant
[Applaudissements]
de recevoir le patron de C8 pendant
c'est avec lui
[Musique]
de recevoir Nadia pour faire le choix
avec elle
et même pas deux heures après ben de
recevoir le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est le départ de Nadia quoi
ils ont cru qu'on se met Johnny Hallyday
on a pas le début de l'émission j'ai
rien qu'on voit le début de l'émission
C'est où là vidéo d'entrée on l'a on l'a
le tout début de l'émission vous verrez
on va le voir dans un instant parce que
moi en fait non face à Baba comme la
saison dernière c'est vrai que
l'émission est longue et moi à chaque
fois j'ai passé mon temps à croire que
l'émission était finie mais non regardez
on est en direct avec notre ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin qui est avec
nous depuis 21h15 on dirait que tu as
plus de deux heures déjà c'est vrai que
c'est déjà 23h22 je vous laisse aller
vous coucher après
merci d'être avec nous des 23h29 c'est
experts
ministère au gouvernement pardon je
commence un peu à fatiguer moi aussi
pour 155000 pour 155000 policiers
avec nous merci à vous merci à tous
d'avoir été
sur Internet merci beaucoup merci au
revoir
des missions en direct
trois heures d’émission direct derrière
et je vous le dis après il est venu me
voir dans ma loge il m'a dit allez on y
va vraiment comme ça
et sachez le j'ai envie de lancer un
nouveau principe et je le dis parce que
hier voilà j'ai lancé un appel Olivier
verront hier le porte-parole du
gouvernement Gérald Darmanin on va aller
la semaine prochaine dans un
commissariat ensemble on dira pas lequel
on va y aller en surprise voilà
avec Gérard Darmanin je vais lancer des
install live comme ça donc l'essence
avec Olivier Veyron s'il veut bien le
commissariat avec Gérald Darmanin
peut-être aller acheter un col roulé
avec Bruno Le Maire
donc aujourd'hui le col roulé de Bruno
donc on ira voilà on a acheté son col
roulé voilà donc c'est un nouveau un
nouveau un nouveau truc sur Instagram
donc voilà je vous tiens au courant mais
ça va démarrer déjà la semaine prochaine
avec avec le ministre de l'Intérieur et
j'espère qu'Olivier Véran va dire oui
pour mon invitation d'aller chercher de
l'essence c'est moi qui paye t'inquiète
pas
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau Olivier a
été avec nous c'est Vanessa qui était
avec nous hier policière qui a fait
énormément parler d'elle c'est la star
de la soirée un génie bientôt Laura son
face à Baba merci d'être là en tout cas
on va revenir sur votre prestation hier
et sur ce qui s'est passé vous allez me
dire comment vous avez trouvé votre chef
moi je vous invite dans mon commissariat
sans aucun problème
du papier Brossard
quand je suis invité quelque part
c'était ma tradition alors pour ceux qui
ont loupé on a le début de l'émission et
c'est vrai que le début de l'émission là
on avait l'impression d'être c'est vrai
que c'était le Zénith on a mis tout
l'argent qu'on avait en lumière
voilà là c'était chaud là je peux vous
dire on est allé chez régalie on a été
on a été fort c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous
merci merci
d'être avec nous
dans ce nouveau numéro de face à Baba il
est 21h16 nous sommes en direct sur 8 et
ce soir nous recevons notre ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin merci à vous
merci
Gérard Darmanin
alors on peut le dire c'est chaud quand
tu es tout seul sur le plateau sur le
siège tu entends la musique de Rondo
vénéziano tu as l'impression que le mec
il est derrière toi en train de jouer du
violon je peux dire c'est comme ça je
peux tenir que là tu te dis là je me
fais tout petit franchement bravo aux
équipes d'ailleurs franchement très fort
ils ont pas voulu arrêter les lumières
leçons ils sont dit tiens on tient un
truc c'était interminable alors c'est un
événement assez exceptionnel émission
intérieure a quand même accepté de venir
faire l'émission c'était la première
avec cette nouvelle formule regardez
pourquoi vous êtes venus déjà parce que
c'est vrai que c'est la première c'est
une nouvelle formule c'est quand même un
gros risque d'abord bonsoir et d'abord
j'ai dit oui parce que vous m'avez
invité donc moi je suis un garçon poli
donc tous les Français qui vous invitent
de choses sérieuses tout va bien se
passer voilà donc c'est vrai voilà donc
ça devrait bien se passer ce soir ça a
été pour le trajet parce que je sais
qu'on a une maire de Paris qui s'appelle
Annie delgot qui compliquait
donc ça va vous avez pu venir facilement
mais moi j'ai pas la même vie que tout
le monde et j'en ai bien conscient j'ai
fait c'est une étude éthique de l'île et
je serai en 4e année j'ai redoublé deux
fois moi au collège ça donne de l'espoir
exactement
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'était voilà
on a démarré assez sympathiquement avec
le milieu intérieur comment vous l'avez
trouvé moi je l'ai trouvé très pertinent
parce que quand même il a été toute la
soirée confronté à des gens qui lui
racontait des drames qui expliquait une
situation difficile j'ai trouvé que
jamais il s'énerver jamais il flanchait
il était très concret et ce qui était
bien c'était la confrontation entre des
gens du réel et le ministre c'était pas
vous aviez changé c'est plus des
chroniqueurs professionnels plus des
analystes et j'ai trouvé que cette
confrontation avec le réel ça apportait
plein d'infos et plein de vie à
l'émission moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
Delphine moi j'ai adoré il était
vraiment dans l'empathie il était humble
ça change des des politiques en règle
générale il était à l'écoute et il a il
a gardé son son calme aussi par moment
parce que c'était c'était quand même
beaucoup beaucoup d'attaques mais je
l'ai trouvé très très bien alors hier on
a reçu beaucoup d'invités qui ont marqué
l'actualité René et l'un d'entre eux
c'est le fils d'Angèle à 80 novembre
lâchement agressé par trois mineurs à
Cannes il a tenu à venir avec sa maman
Angèle qu'on a vu hier qui était
magnifique franchement elle est su je
suis tellement heureux voilà qui est sur
le retour vous allez la voir hier on l'a
vu j'étais content de l'avoir comme ça
en gel un amour et il s'est directement
adressé au ministre de l'Intérieur sur
le thème de la sécurité regardez
des trucs comme ça monsieur le
ministrement mais moi j'étais jeune
[Musique]
dans la rue
on a plus le droit de les éduquer avant
on allait à l'école on se prenait un
coup de pied au cul ou une gifle ça
jamais tuer personne mais pour les
suivre ces jeunes il faut il faut
arrêter là ça va plus là ça va vraiment
plus là
qui sont dangereux ils deviennent
dangereux est-ce que vous avez vu le
couple ma mère elle a pris est-ce que la
force de l'agression mais c'est pas
c'est pas une agression pour prendre un
sac ça moi ma mère je la vois morte je
l'ai déjà dit dans un autre mission je
la vois morte ma mère
c'était un moment très très fort il y
avait des moments de vérité et puis on
n'a pas accès au ministre personne ne
peut lui parler comme ça c'était d'une
force vraiment et lui est courageux
d'avoir fait face à ça parce que c'est
on est dans le réel dans le dans le
drame du réel quoi c'est vraiment très
fort très émouvant
qu'on vous aime pas dans cette émission
et ça il y a aucune autre émission
politique qui qui le fait le l'invité il
est pas agressé il est pas
dans le thé choyé et il se passe quelque
chose et ça honnêtement c'est pas parce
que c'est vous en même temps c'est vous
ça tombe bien mais mais ce qui vous aime
pas ils doivent être d'avoir le seum
parce que vous êtes le seul qui peut
parler avec un avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur aussi simplement avec des
questions qui sont les directs et ça je
pense que c'est du jamais vu en télé et
c'est vrai que la politique par des gens
qui sont comme des coluches les milieux
autorisés à penser c'est quand même
épouvantable ben ça fait chier tout le
monde et là effectivement il s'est passé
quelque chose donc franchement bravo et
c'est vrai qu'il existe un bonheur était
très très bon j'ai vraiment eu bravo aux
équipes parce que les intervenants
étaient incroyables notamment Jérôme et
Jérôme va-t-elle le fils de
Jean-Baptiste 92 ans et il nous a appris
la mort de son père après avoir été
sauvagement agressé le 9 septembre
dernier à la porte de la Villette il a
annoncé en direct le décès de son père
regarde
bonsoir monsieur le ministre
mon père est décédé mardi comment ça
votre père est décédé
le choc parlez bien le micro-jérôme
c'est
quand vous êtes venus parce que vous me
disiez 92 ans
c'est triste c'est plus que triste c'est
plus que triste j'ai jamais autant
pleuré de ma vie je n'ai jamais pleuré
auparavant et là j'ai pleuré toutes mes
larmes pendant un mois et demi
c'est très fort le témoignage de Jérôme
m'envoyant encore ému un Daniel j'ai
pleuré hier vraiment c'est trop triste
et c'est trop on
est triste quoi et bon il a essayé de
répondre il a fait ce qu'il a pu mais on
se c'est un exemple vraiment de
l'impuissance du gouvernement de la
France le crack c'est horrible et là
c'est le symbole si ça pouvait faire
changer les choses si on pouvait pas
seulement être triste et puis pleurer de
sur autre chose après encore autre chose
voilà c'est vrai qu'il y a en voyant
cette émission voyant le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui s'est fait voilà ce qui
peut on se dit il y a énormément de
travail vraiment c'est c'est énormément
de travail et il faut que ça aille plus
vite il faut que ça aille plus loin et
c'est vrai que c'est c'est vraiment
c'est c'est ce courtier je me dis là
c'est un chantier immense il a reconnu
les difficultés à chaque fois il disait
que j'ai proposé ça ça ne suffit pas ou
je n'ai pas fait ça je le regrette il y
a un truc aussi voyez on en parle un
petit peu tout à l'heure des donneurs de
leçons aussi un petit peu voilà qu'on
voit sur les réseaux sociaux qui on en
parlait donc parler de ça il y a un
instant avec ceux qui essaient de nous
attaquer aussi et ça c'est beaucoup
revenu aussi il disait à chaque fois on
est tombé dessus on a dit que j'avais
fait ça et c'est vrai que le conseil que
j'ai essayé de lui bien c'est il faut
qu'il trace parce que si il commence à
écouter les uns les autres les biens
pensants à un moment
les Français
ont voté voilà ils ont voté aujourd'hui
voilà c'est Emmanuel Macron le Président
on soit content ou pas maintenant il
faut que tous il faut laisser de
l'essayer de les laisser
faire le maximum parce que si voilà les
donneurs ne le sont sur les réseaux
sociaux qui font rien aussi je peux vous
dire si vous les écoutez on n'avance pas
et c'est vrai que ce que je vais essayer
de lui dire parfois il faut qu'il arrive
il arrête de penser et il l'a dit voilà
l'opinion publique à ce que vont dire
les gens etc il est les gens ont besoin
de mesures fortes ils ont besoin de
renforcer l'autorité de la police ils
ont besoin de renforcer l'autorité des
enseignants ils ont besoin de de que les
Français sur
se retrouvent un peu en sécurité
aujourd'hui que comme on l'a vu c'est
vrai que il y a des choses qui se
passent qui se passaient pas avant et
les gens ont de plus en plus peur mais
c'est vrai que si on commence à écouter
les uns et les autres là on n'avance pas
et c'est vrai qu'à un moment faut foncer
qui t'a
qui t'a déplaire à énormément de monde
mais il faut essayer d'avancer d'essayer
de faire les choses oui d'ailleurs il a
commencé très fort parce qu'il a utilisé
le mot de en sauvagement et moi je sais
pas si vous souvenez il y a quelques
semaines j'avais utilisé il a dit qu'on
insiste un nom sauvagement de la société
française et je trouve que c'est très
courageux quand on est ministre de
l'Intérieur de dire que oui aujourd'hui
il y a un nom sauvagement de la société
on n'a pas la réponse à tout et j'ai
trouvé que hier pour le coup de
l'assumer et de le dire comme ça c'était
quand même très très fort voilà mais
après il a pas moi il m'a il m'a apporté
des réponses que je n'avais pas et j'ai
trouvé que c'était bien parce qu'il a
montré aussi toute l'absurdité et le
côté kafkaïen du système ça ressemble un
oculteur je savais pas que par exemple
qui le savait que la personne pouvait
faire 12 fois appel 12 fois
pour que éventuellement ce soit quatre
fois donc ça c'est très concret et on a
on a fait quand même
et j'ai une petite discussion avec lui
après je lui dis le gros problème aussi
et la justice fait bien son travail il
essaie de faire le maximum mais il y a
un gros problème c'est que il faut que
le ministre de l'Intérieur travaille
avec le garde des sceaux mais le
ministre de la justice parce que un
moment c'est comme les policiers qui
vous disent elles sont on va les attrape
et on va attraper des lincons on va les
mettre en prison ils vont ressortir deux
jours après aujourd'hui c'est ça le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il faut
qu'il y ait que le ministère de la
Justice et le ministère de l'Intérieur
travaillent main dans la main et
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que il y a
il y a les policiers ou voilà qui font
leur boulot et derrière la justice elle
fait c'est plus compliqué donc il y a
tellement de lois tellement de et
aujourd'hui je vous dis il y a tellement
aussi de filouterie j'ai envie de dire
pour essayer de passer à travers les
mailles du filet que bah un moment même
les policiers ils disent bah de toute
façon je vais pas aller risquer ma vie
parce que qu'est-ce que l'on sait je
vais peut-être risqué ma vie pour un
truc alors que dans deux trois jours ou
une semaine et ils seront sortis
non franchement oui tout à fait oui oui
tout à fait non c'est vrai que la la
réitération et enfin c'est hallucinant
on intervient on intervient c'est ce
qu'on dit toujours sur les mêmes
toujours sur les mêmes et quand on les
voit ressortir et même il y a une
arrogance et il le savent je veux dire
dans l'absolu quand vous interpellez un
individu et que au bout de 24 heures ou
48 heures de garde à vue et ressort et
vous fait un gros bras d'honneur en
disant ben voilà j'ai rien de plus
qu'est-ce que vous voulez au bout d'un
moment il y en a marre nous on a
l'impression vraiment de qu'on sert à
rien et ce qui nous fait le plus mal
c'est que
ce sont les victimes qui sont une
nouvelle fois victime de ça elles sont
victimes à la base de ce qui leur est
arrivé et elles sont victimes en plus de
ça quand vous voyez que vous mettez
quelqu'un en garde à vue il a le droit à
l'avocat à passer un coup de fil à
aviser à viser le
quelqu'un de sa famille avoir un médecin
et la victime on n'est même pas capable
de lui apporter un avocat pour la
soutenir lors d'une d'une audition ou
d'une confrontation elle doit payer de
sa poche principale on est quand même
c'est quand même hallucinant c'est vrai
et on l'a vu on l'a vu on va voir votre
échange avec Gérald Darmanin de parole
elle est folle on va la voir vous allez
me dire ce que comment vous l'avez senti
est-ce que vous étiez stressé avant de
parler
votre police elle craque votre police
elle en peut plus parce que on est
détesté bon on a l'habitude
on nous insulte ça à la limite on a
l'habitude
on nous tue
et moi je suis maire de famille comme
beaucoup de mes collègues j'ai pas envie
de crever au bout d'un moment monsieur
le ministre qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
la justice nous laisse tomber
sauf pour nous sanctionner on est qui on
est plus rien en fait on est plus
personne comment voulez-vous qu'on vous
protège si on nous protège pas à nous
aussi au bout d'un moment monsieur le
ministre on va péter un plomb
c'était un des moments très fort hier de
face à vos vacances quand vous êtes
senti face au ministre
[Rires]
et j'ai pu lui dire en fait ce que je
veux pas avoir la prétention de
représenter tous mes collègues loin de
là parce que il y aura des critiques
bien évidemment chez nous aussi mais peu
importe ce que je veux dire c'est que
beaucoup de collègues pensent comme moi
et en fait on est on est un groupe et il
a il faut qu'il l'entende et on s'est vu
même après l'émission on en a discuté
etc je lui dis mais venez
la discuté avec tout le monde
faut pas rester là
j'arrive
[Rires]
il est en train de passer le balai dans
le couloir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et j'ai beaucoup discuté avec lui après
et je lui ai dit je lui ai dit mais
venez on va s'asseoir autour d'une table
et puis on va discuter mais venez parler
avec les mecs de terrain et c'est vrai
qu'il le fait et il va venir il m'a
promis qu'il allait qu'il allait venir
dans dans mon cerve
non je pense qu'il va mieux il va venir
vous dire en tout cas nous viendrons et
vous viendrez nous dire comment ça
comment ça s'est passé Vanessa vous avez
été excellente en tout cas merci
vraiment ça fait du bien et moi je
voudrais dire un petit truc parce que il
y a aussi beaucoup de gens qui ont
stigmatisé aussi les jeunes de banlieue
quand ils ont entendu voilà le
témoignage de Vanessa etc là aussi il
faut pas c'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir je vous le dis moi j'ai vu voilà on
est encore vu la semaine dernière vous
avez vu les jeunes de banlieue qui qui
aident les gens à abandonner moi je suis
un gamin voilà je viens de la banlieue
Gérard Darmanin aussi d'ailleurs et il
en a beaucoup parlé et c'est vrai que
voilà nous pour la plus
pour elle à 90% c'est comme les
policiers il y en a des très hauts il y
en a des voilà j'ai une anecdote
justement à ce propos pour que je sais
bien aussi qu'on montre que en banlieue
il y a des choses vraiment incroyables
qui sont faites moi je vais vous dire si
j'étais pas issu de la banlieue je pense
que j'aurais été pas ici celui que je
suis aujourd'hui et voilà et celui et
voilà je pense que j'aurais pas fait la
la la petite carrière que je suis en
train de faire mais c'est vrai que je
lis parce que ça positivement l'argent
qui créent qui se démêlent exactement il
y a énormément de gens le problème mais
j'ai même qui gangrène j'ai une anecdote
justement pour rebondir sur ce que vous
dites un jour on nous appelle pour
intervenir pour un petit un petit bout
de deux ans et demi qui est tout seul au
milieu de la cité donc on arrive il a
été pris en charge par un monsieur et
tous les jeunes de la cité sont venus
autour de nous mais c'était pas du tout
agressif et là on a commencé à dire mais
d'où il vient ce petit est-ce que vous
le connaissez etc personne ne le
connaissait et à ce moment là
il s'est mis en place une dynamique où
le un des jeunes me dit est-ce que je
peux le prendre en photo et le mettre
sur les réseaux sociaux le petit on va
tous partager et il appelait ses potes
en disant ouais tu partages j'ai envoyé
un truc etc et on a retrouvé voilà le
les parents comme ça et ça a été une
dynamique et ça a été vraiment une belle
expérience et à aucun moment mes
collègues de moi-même on s'est senti en
dangereux et je vais vous dire quand je
le vois
tous les jeunes qui m'écrivent qui est
que je vois que il me dit juste on veut
pas se sentir
laisser de côté on veut se sentir aussi
on veut qu'on nous parle on veut qu'on
nous compte on veut qu'on veut qu'on
qu'on essaie de nous parler qui est en
échange et c'est vrai que voilà il faut
y changer il faut essayer de de parler
de le plus possible essayer de aussi de
les aider parce qu'il y en a voilà c'est
c'est pas voilà c'est il y en a qui qui
vivent des moments difficiles aussi qui
ont pas une voilà et qui essaie de s'en
sortir et qui sont plus voilà qui sont
on a l'impression qu'on en fout la tête
sous l'eau voilà donc il faut essayer
exactement voilà tout ce qu'ils font de
toute façon
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
mais en même temps je veux dire nous
aussi on est stigmatise que dans
l'absolu voilà on arrive avec un
uniforme on sait pas qui je suis et on
va m'insulter parce que je porte cette
uniforme
des rencontres entre eux c'est vrai que
ça c'est ça c'est parce que dès que ça
dialogue moi je vois que ça se passe
bien et que ça dialogue aussi et puis il
y a des Hoshi je vous dis aussi il y a
des collègues à vous et vous l'avez dit
ils sont pas loin qui aussi qui qui ont
là qui ont une approche où ils arrivent
déjà le premier mot et la la la le
premier contact et assez il est il est
plutôt voilà il est plutôt agressif donc
forcément ça met tout de suite voilà et
c'est il faudrait que ça quand vous me
racontez votre histoire c'est vrai que
là voilà on se dit que quand ça discute
quand ça marche et comme vous dites dans
la police il y en a des moins des
mauvais en banlieue il y a des bons il y
a des mauvais ici sur le bateau il y a
surtout des mauvais euh
pour revenir sur l'émission elle-même je
trouve qu'elle a beaucoup évolué je
trouve que avant face à ma base c'était
une mission qui parlait d'actu qui
recevait ceux qui font la queue
maintenant vous créez l'actu je sais pas
si vous avez vu ce matin sur les chaînes
info il y avait plein d'extraits en
boucle de l'émission sur BFM sur cnews
et il parlait pas voilà et il parlait
pas que de la forme c'est-à-dire Hanouna
face à un politique et parler du fond et
des choses qui étaient dites dans
l'émission et en ça ça a vraiment évolué
c'est devenu une émission crédible sur
le plan politique